despite the critical success of True
Detective the Show's first season was
criticized for its portrayal of women
particularly one article for the New
Yorker cited Alexander diario's
character as an example of the show's
gratuitous nudity and accused the
showrunners of featuring underwritten
female characters who reveal more of
their physical bodies than of their
personalities in an interview with The
Daily Beast tario rejected these claims
of True Detective being misogynistic
saying I feel like the story was about
these two flawed men and the women
especially my character and Lily Simmons
character were there to propel their
story lines forward she further
explained that she and the other women
on the show also experienced a surge of
interest from Hollywood after their
appearances which gave them more power
in Show Biz rather than less